[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is Sean fedora if you don't
know me I hope you never meet somebody
like me again that's because I've
survived cancer four times four times
over the course of seven and a half
years I've had leukemia a bone marrow
transplant chemo radiation I've had a
craniotomy which is basically a fancy
term that doctors use for cutting my
head open from this year to this year
pulling down my face then use a drill to
pull out the tumor the size of a golf
ball yeah
fifth grade was not very fun I had many
memories of cancer some good some bad I
remember my family visiting me cousins
you know all my aunts and uncles having
good times watching movies pulling
all-nighters maybe being the most
competitive bingo player ever but some
of my most memorable moments were with
steroids
now when I say steroids most people
think of steroids like Barry Bonds you
know get ripped muscular or or like
Lance Armstrong or every single biker
ever know I had a different type and uh
well to put it like lightly this
steroids made me angry
I was mad all the time and I complain
about just about everything I had the
temper of a 1000 Donald Trump's now one
time during Lent after church I was
walking outside and an old lady started
to approach me and she was she was
shaking she was more nervous than me
giving a speech right now and she said
now now Shawn what are you giving up for
live this year I looked her straight in
the eyes and I said duh my hair now all
jokes aside cancer was a challenge for
me
I remember being held down by four to
five nurses getting needles in my chest
which is by the way way scarier than
public speaking and I met lots of
friends we fought with each other and
most of my friends didn't make it one of
my friend's name was Tyler one day my
dad took Tyler me to go see a movie how
I was 14 years old and he just had a
relapse Tyler said to my dad mr. fidella
all I want to do is drive the car Tyler
passed away on March 15 2012 he was 14
years old he was never able to drive a
car it's moments like these
and people like Tyler that make me
wonder why why me out of all my friends
why did I survive there has to be a
reason and I think I know an answer and
I'd like to share it with you I believe
it's my purpose to raise awareness about
the money allocated to pediatric cancer
research you know out of all the money
raised the millions billions of dollars
raised to fight all cancers
pediatric cancer only is 4% kids like
you kids like me and kids like Tyler and
it's only 4% children die every day from
cancer and they did nothing to deserve
it we need to fight we need to make a
change we need to have more than four
and I think I can fix it I think I have
a solution well here it goes
ladies and gentlemen sports in America
we worship the athletes who walk the
hardwood courts in awesome fields we
wear Jordans because they wear Jordans
we buy jerseys with their names on them
because we want to be like them
now when you look at this picture what
do you notice what stands out now does
anyone know what pink stands for yes
when October rolls around the whole
sports world is painted pink everyone
comes together for a great cause and a
great message that helps breast cancer
survivors and patients fight breast
cancer now just like breast cancer uses
pink as their color we could use gold
which is the color for pediatric cancer
awareness gold on gloves gold on cleats
going on clothes
we can fight pediatric cancer I can see
it now it's the first sunday of the NFL
season a hundred thousand fans chanting
anticipating a great kickoff and out of
the tunnels out of the corners of the
stadium a bore of gold
streaks across the field thousands of
fans chanting in the Gold Gloves in
cleats glisten in the Sunday morning Sun
all players from different places
with different dreams and different
hopes come together for one cause in one
color gold we need to fight pediatric
cancer and I believe that this is a way
to do it from peewee it's a professional
from kickers to coaches from goalies to
guards everyone can wear gold in
September my goal is that by this time
next year everybody knows that September
is a month for raising awareness for
childhood cancer research and that gold
is the color for finding a cure for
childhood cancer now don't take my word
for it
Who am I just a random kid from Mountain
Brook Alabama why don't you take the
number three pick in the 2016 NFL Draft
Joey Bosa
word for it I'm jelly basta former
defensive end at the Ohio State
University and I believe our children
deserve more than four and why don't you
take defensive lineman from Iowa State
University
Mitchell Meyers word for it hi my name
is Mitchell Meyers I play football at
Iowa State University and I'm a cancer
survivor our kids deserve more than four
and since we're in New York why don't
you take arguably the greatest New York
Yankees pitcher ever Andy Pettitte hi
this is Andy Pettit former pitcher of
the New York Yankees and Houston Astros
our kids deserve more than four hi my
name is Sean Trudeau
our kids deserve more than four Tyler
deserves more than four Sebastian
deserves more than four Andrew deserves
more than four we deserve more than four
thank you
[Applause]